the most important news first, with
today's decision on co2
reductions for vehicles, we're
putting clean mobility in europe in the
fast lane
from 8.30
p.m
passenger cars should be 35 percent
lower than everyone
else in 20 21 this morning,
for example, germany should have passed the target
of 30 percent and
in very intensive
negotiations we have also succeeded in convincing our german
colleagues and other countries of
their ambitions  to increase to 35
percent
and last but not least, i have
also put the topic of a look at plastic on the
agenda today
it is about us
wanting to significantly reduce the consumption of plastic items in europe
,
in particular the use of single-use
plastic should be reduced to zero  become
[music]